الى اي مدا من الناحيه القانونيه تبدو
الامور مهيئه لجمع ادله على المستوى
القانوني لادانه هذه الجرائم يعني نتحدث
هنا عن قتل نساء حوامل نتحدث عن خطاب
تحريضي ايضا نستمع الى ذلك في بشكل علني
في وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه عن قتل
الحوامل والاطفال وكبار السن الى اي مد
يبدو الوضع قانونيا
متاحا ما اتيتم به من توثيق هذه المشاهد
المؤلمه هو امر مهم جدا على مستوى بناء
ماده توثيقيه لاي محاكمات قد تجري مستقبلا
اسف ان اقول مستقبلا لان العداله الجنائيه
الدوليه معطله حاليا من قبل مجلس الامن
الدولي نفسه الذي يعود اليه حفظ الامن
والسلم العالميين الذي تعود اليه صلاحيه
الاحاله الى المحكمه المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه الدائمه المنشاه بمقتضى نظام روما
لعام 1998 او انشاء اي محكمه خاصه ادهك
اعتقد اننا امام وقائع تتخطى بكثير اي
قضيه احيلت الى المحاكم الجنائيه
الدوليه بدء ب نورنبرغ مرورا بمحكمه روما
وسائر المحاكم الخاصه التي انشات نحن امام
فضائع استثنائيه جدا هائله من حيث الحجم
ومن حيث الاثار ومن حيث تخطي قواعد
القانون الدولي الانساني وليس القانون
المذكور فحسب انما ايضا اي قواعد عرفيه اي
قواعد عرفيه يعني عندما تهجم القبائل مرات
عديده في التاريخ وهذا التعبير القبائلي
هو امر حميد ونبيل قياسا على ما نشهده
فانها لا ترتكب بحق الاحياء او المدن او
القرى السكنيه ما ترتكبه اسرائيل وه وهل
يمكن ان تخرج اسرائيل سالمه على المستوى
القانوني من هذه الجرائم كما حدث لجرائم
عبر التاريخ القانون لم يفعل شيئا
ازاءه انظر معي عندما اعيد تحريك الملف من
قبل المدعي العام امام المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه دائما اي السيد كريم خان اريد له
ان يوازن بين ما يجري من ارتكابات جسيمه
للقانون الدولي الانساني راهنا من قبل
اسرائيل وبينما جرى في السابع من اكتوبر
ولذلك دعي الى اسرائيل عندما منع في المره
الاولى من اجتياز المعبر للدخول الى قطاع
غزه فبالتالي على الاقل اذا اتيح
للعداله الجنائيه الدوليه ان تسك مسارها
يوما ما فانه يراد ايضا اقحام موضوع
السابع من اكتوبر في هذه الاحداث ولا باس
من ذلك يعني لسنا ضد هذا الامر على الاقل
فلتترك العداله الجنائيه الدوليه تحرك ان
لم يكن من مجلس الامن المعطل فعلى الاقل
من قبل مساعي المدعي العام المذكور رغم
التحفظ الذي اشرت اليه واي ايضا بدفع من
قبل الدول الخمس التي تقدمت بعريضه مطالبه
تحريك هذه المحكمه والتي لم نشهد لغايه
اليوم اي تفعيل هذا المسار رغم الجهود
التي تنصب في هذا الاتجاه وبصيص الامل هو
قليل حاضرا لكن هذه الجرائم لا تسقط بمرور
الزمن مهما طال الزمن